the darkness comes to us from the
director of Wolf Creek and it stars
Kevin Bacon and rod ha Mitchell as a
couple with two children who go on
vacation in the Grand Canyon this kid
picks up some weird rocks that he finds
and brings these rocks back to the house
after that shit gets weird I do want to
make sure you know to stay tuned to the
end of this video cuz I'm gonna be
talking about a sponsorship I'm doing
with loot crate afterwards I went to
this movie excited I love scary movies
Kevin Bacon is one of my favorite actors
I also like Radha Mitchell a lot she's
very good and you know the trailer was a
trailer and I just went and saw it for
fun and and did shit this movie's
horrible uh I feel bad because I'm a fan
of Kevin Bacon and the movie actually
started out semi promising there was
some good set up despite the fact that
it was about some kid who stole five
rocks the setup was intriguing at least
there there was some intriguing
possibilities with this movie and it
just divulge 'iz into a gigantic string
of horror cliches 101 and if you think
I'm joking I'm not literally everything
about this movie is a cliche nothing
happens forever doors open who opened
the door
I don't know lights turn on and off and
act strange weird electrical occurrences
strange sounds at night the television
turns on on its own the garage door
opened on its own all kinds of shit like
that for like an hour not kidding and of
course the young boy is the only one
aware of the presence of this ancient
evil that's invaded their home because
he's a young boy now the whole thing of
the movie is that this young child is
autistic
and due to his mental illness the family
just accepts all of the strange things
he keeps doing when in reality he's
interacting with some sort of ancient
evil that's in their house and they all
just think oh you know he's just being
him no he stole some rocks and you guys
are fucked I like Kevin Bacon I like
Kevin Bacon a lot bacon goes good with
anything that's what I always say but
the poor guy is stranded in this movie I
mean stranded they try to give him
something it's almost like he and Rod ha
Mitchell attempt to
have something some marital strain
family strain with their daughter and
they try to bring that into the movie to
try to make it something and it just
keeps being weighed down by jump scares
and weird handprints on the walls and
things that never lead to anything the
sad thing is is when it actually does
lead to something and you see behind the
curtain and you understand what's
happening here I mean I was nearly
laughing and I feel bad saying that I
don't like hating on movies I love
horror films I'm always pulling for
filmmakers to make good films because I
understand how hard it is to make a
movie it's tough this just has studio
made a movie with horror cliches and
hope to make a profit written all over
it I mean they can't even figure out a
way to explain the mythology behind this
ancient evil that's taken over their
house so they just sit these characters
down and have them watch a long string
of YouTube videos and if they just did
that in one scene I would have been like
really come on oh well but they do it
again in another scene it's like they
have to have every character that doubts
the possibility of this supernatural
presence watch youtube videos about it
look I'm not gonna talk anymore about
this stupid movie fuck it I mean the
kids stole some rocks that's the movie
he stole rocks I'm gonna give the
darkness a d-minus because Kevin Bacon
and Rod ha Mitchell tried they really
did and that's about it if you want a
good Kevin Bacon supernatural thriller
just don't go see The Darkness I'm
serious and just stay home and watch
stir of echoes this movie is
surprisingly good and very underrated
that's why it's back there good Kevin
Bacon horror film check it out sometimes
like I said I am running a sponsorship
with loot crate right now and they're
doing a very special crate for May as
you guys know and if you don't know loot
crate is the awesome geek monthly
subscription box that comes with tons of
amazing stuff that just makes you want
to salivate and just put it everywhere
and look at it the make raid is going to
have two Marvel items plus Warcraft and
Dragon Ball Z related products Dragon
Ball Z for life my friends for less than
20 bucks a month you get four to eight
items gear clothing toys collectibles if
you sign up at loot crate comm slash
Chris Stockman and use the coupon code
Chris you have until May 19
at 9:00 p.m. Pacific time to get 10% off
you guys are the best thank you so much
as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes